for a lot of people weight loss and
wellness are on the mind as we take on a
new year anti-aging expert Erica Lauren
of parasol Aesthetics Dermatology and
wellness the sponsors of this segment
you are here to help you are back to
help because you've been here before
helping us stay fresh okay so now you
guys are a full Med Spa you know I'm
sure this is a really busy time for you
it is I mean who didn't indulge during
December eating cookies and cake I know
I did yeah me too me too so we have a
lot of people coming in who are asking
like how do I shed these packs yeah
definitely now shedding pounds but you
know in the Hollywood way there's a new
Hollywood Trend out there that all the
stars are using what is that so you've
probably heard a lot the name ozempic in
the media and people are starting to
Google it because they're starting to
see the name connected with the
Kardashians so Mindy Kaling and then
Elon Musk came out and said you know how
have you been losing the weight he's
like I've been using ozempic interesting
okay so men and women out there this is
really you so how does it work what does
it do so it's impact it's actually
semi-glutide which was originally used
for diabetes and they found that people
who had diabetes they were losing weight
so American Medical Society did a test
and saw that 15 of the people who were
on this lost a lot of weight while they
were on this medication interesting
interesting so it helps to balance
glucose and insulin levels in the body
but it also helps you to suppress your
appetite so you lose quite a bit without
a lot of side effects on it okay now
this is you know in the what's the
process like it's just I think one
needle one shot what's what's the deal
one injection a week okay fatty area
okay like belly you can do your arms
your thighs little tiny needles so it's
not that bad not too bad and then you
have it right here this is all this is
all it takes doesn't look too you know
it doesn't look too edible scary you
know it's like too scary now you also
have some other more natural options for
weight loss during the new year right
yes so we have some of the tried and
true options and we have natural options
there's one more I wanted to mention
called please remain okay so Phentermine
is a tried and true one that's been
around for years but it is a stimulant
medication so it helps you have a lot of
energy while you're on it helps you to
burn fat okay but it's like having
multiple cups of java so you won't need
any coffee in the morning oh please okay
I'll take it I'll take it now the three
natural options yes so the other the
natural options would be used doing
something like B12 lipo boost injections
which I have in here so this actually
has a lipo boost as a mick and they are
things that help to increase metabolism
of like protein fats carbohydrates still
give you energy also little tiny
injection you can see how small insulins
are yeah that goes in a fatty area
you'll pinch it up you'll inject it into
the area and you'll get a lot of energy
and lose weight while you're doing it
okay and then we have just we only have
we have no more time the two other
options just name them really quick okay
so I also have craving curb which is
part of my line and that has natural
elements to help to lose weight weight
and we also have some things we can
inject into the fat themselves called
mesotherapy okay well for more you got
to go to Parasol Aesthetics so thank you
parasol Aesthetics Dermatology and
wellness for sponsoring this segment
give them a call
702-560-6776 or you can visit that
website right there on your screen now
they do have a special offer for you
it's the Hollywood slim package that's
normally three thousand dollars and now
it is just under 2 000 okay so give them
a call thank you Erica we'll be right
back
[Music]